exact science but when we take attitudes
on polling and we check attitudes from
when I started which was 45 years ago
about one of out of three Americans was
infected seriously infected with
anti-semitism today 45 years later not
all am i doing or even the ADL but
changing society and environment some
litigation legislation education it's
down to about twelve fourteen percent of
the American public twelve fourteen
percent still is 40 million Americans
which is still quite serious and we're
talking about somebody who's seriously
infected and I'm sure there's another
forty million who may believe Jews are
too powerful and and financed or they
control the government or or Hollywood
or or killed Christ or are loyal and
these are all stereotypes of
anti-semitism that still exist but on
the whole it has changed and because at
least it's unacceptable that means it's
it's not PC to be an anti-semitic and so
from that perspective I think fewer
people engage in Adam the greatest
challenge a new challenge we face is
when we're engaged in now and that's the
internet when the World Wide Web
on one hand on one hand it's a
magnificent boon to education to
interaction to communication in all
kinds of ways but it also has provided a
dark underbelly of a superhighway for
bigotry these are the unintended
consequences of this magnificent
creation and mention and expansion of of
dialog and information but you can today
anonymously communicate bigotry in
nanoseconds across the globe in the 50s
the anti-defamation league helped model
an advocate a law called the anti
masking law which we helped
enact in the state of Georgia of all
people and what that law said is if you
want to be a bigot if you want to
demonstrate them protest as a bigot
that's your right under the Constitution
but you can't have your head covered you
can't hide your identity
you can't white wear a white mask or
black mask or a purple mask you have to
take responsibility for your bigotry and
in fact that was the law that had the
greatest impact to break the back of the
Ku Klux Klan because all these bigots
who were all ready to do their bigotry
hiding their identity who happened have
been lawyers and store keepers and
judges and whatever all of a sudden lost
their courage fast forward 50 years
later and that mask has been put back
through the internet and so today you
could be a bigot you could be a bigot
anonymously
you can enter somebody's home there and
invade their privacy and we see it we
see it so dramatic in in cyberbully